all right well the governor's race is
not the only election in virginia
tomorrow as the fight for the next state
attorney general wraps up jason miatas
is the son of a cuban exile and he's
looking to become virginia's first ever
latino elected as a.g virginia attorney
general candidate jason miatas joins me
now jason welcome to prime time um so
your platform is you know it speaks for
all races but i will say that the latino
race and you happen to be latino
yourself is the latino population about
almost 10 percent so this seems like a
very critical uh vote
tell me how you think that vote will go
and how it has been the reaction to your
candidacy
well listen you're exactly right not
only would i be the first latino ever
elected i'd be the first child of an
immigrant ever elected as attorney
general so i i say to every group
whether it's korean-americans or
indian-americans or latinos
listen if your family came to this
country
seeking hope and opportunity there's a
good chance your family is a lot like my
family may be the biggest honor of my
life to be your attorney general because
every day they want the same things they
are so concerned about what they're
seeing with politicians paying political
gains with the safety of our kids and
our schools they're so concerned about a
parole board in virginia that's letting
out cop killers murders and rapists
sometimes with decades on their sentence
back on the streets early and sometimes
they've committed more crimes they're
seeing inflation through the roof it's
so many as you know rachel latinos are
so many are entrepreneurs that's right
they see how hard it is to start a
business we're 49th in the country and
starting a business right now in
virginia and that's why they are
flocking with us in our polling we're
winning the latino vote and so is glenn
younkin and we have uh really loved
everybody into our campaigns this is not
about left to right in virginia right
now it's about a movement it's about
common sense and that's why we're
winning independence by double digits 12
15 points right now we're ready to win
yeah well you know democrats think they
own hispanics they also think we're
stupid i think they think if they say
racism trump insurrection that then
they'll you know his banks will run out
and vote for for democrats but i know a
lot of uh latinos i actually have family
in virginia um who are hispanic and they
care about crime they care about
education they want crt out of their
school and by the way they kind of miss
the trump economy
well i mean listen at the end of the day
you have as i said this is a common
sense they're so concerned about what
they're seeing with the curriculum in
our schools they're concerned that our
murder rate in virginia is the highest
it's been in two decades and so that's
exactly the point you have one party
rule in richmond and it has been far far
far to the left and so people understand
intuitively we need a check and balance
in richmond i mean everything you're
seeing the mess you're seeing in dc it's
been happening in richmond the last two
years and i like to say common sense
hasn't been very common in state
government i mean they're trying to
reduce from a felony to misdemeanor
assaulting a police officer getting rid
of all mandatory minimums for drug
dealers they ended they passed that bill
that ended the mandatory reporting
requirement of sexual assault and
schools so this is a movement we're
having virginians supporting virginians
that get changed and around the country
people are going to jason4ag.com that
want change people understand right now
the stakes in virginia and that's why
the way we're framing this race you want
a politician that's my opponent you want
a prosecutor i'm your candidate well
jason we wish you all the luck we hope
you can bring back some common sense
especially to the law um in california
in virginia thank you so much jason for
joining us today hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else